so thank you for joining us for the
microsoft research summit 2021
i'm melissa chase i'm a researcher at
microsoft research redmond in the
privacy and cryptography group
and today i'm going to talk about some
of the privacy machine learning research
that we've been doing at microsoft
research
so the basic agenda today is going to be
first to talk about what are the privacy
concerns that come up in machine
learning what
is is this area of research and then i'm
going to talk give an overview of the
research happening here at msr um
and then i'm going to do a bit more of a
deep dive into an area that i've been
working on which is looking at some new
attacks on techspace models
so briefly
machine learning we all know is
extremely powerful it's been used for
all kinds of different exciting tasks
but it requires a lot of data and often
that data comes from users or customers
or patients
and that data can be potentially
sensitive
um so
that brings up a big question of privacy
and the question there is can the model
reveal
uh private information about the
training data
so sort of initial thinking on this
point was that no models should you know
learn general trends not specific data
points otherwise it's overfitting so
probably models don't pick up too much
private data
or on the other extreme models are so
complex we don't even understand them so
how could anyone extract anything
but there's actually been a lot of
research over the last
uh
five to ten years that's showing that
models are very complex which means they
have a lot of space to store a lot of
information and sophisticated attacks
can extract this information
so this is just giving two examples of
attacks that
i think are particularly easy to
visualize so the first is a model
inversion attack
that came out in ccs 2015 that looks at
how to extract
images of from the training data for a
facial recognition system so they train
a facial recognition system and then you
can interact with that system and
actually extract the images of the
recognizable images of the original
people
and then the other is a more recent
paper came out in usenix this year
that's looking at
what
information you can extract with private
information you can extract from large
language models in this case gpg2
so these models are trained on huge
corpuses of data and it turns out that
they actually store very specific
information in this case i think names
phone numbers addresses
email addresses things like that
so we're in this state where we know
machine learning models can be very
powerful and very useful we need data to
build machine learning models
that data may be private or confidential
and we know models can leak information
about training data so what can we do
and that's sort of the basis for the our
research agenda and privacy and machine
learning um here at microsoft research
so um
i'm going to jump now into talking about
sort of how we look at the problem
so we sort of look at the problem as
having having three components so the
first is just understanding what can
models leak
so
here we're trying to design attacks to
understand the leakage and and in
particular we're looking at at different
application settings and trying to
understand
potential adversarial capabilities what
exactly might an adversary have access
to in different settings and different
adversarial goals what what counts as as
as a privacy breach what counts as
success in this case
so that's sort of the first step
understand what the problem is uh the
second step oops
is um
more of a measurement step so how can we
measure leakage
so the ideas is we need some kind of a
metric to look at two algorithms and say
well this one is actually more private
than this one so can we come up with
some relatively efficiently computable
metrics that will help us to get a
quantifiable number on how much leakage
is there
and then the final step is is mitigation
so what can we do this is sort of
the end goal of this whole project is
what can we do to reduce or prevent
leakage
and here we're actually looking in a
couple different directions one is
um
differential privacy so that's sort of
the gold standard for a lot of a lot of
the the
different leakage concerns you might
have so we're looking at how to
integrate and refine that
uh and then the the second is in cases
where differential privacy either isn't
applicable or or can't be used for
other considerations then we want to
look at heuristics that maybe in the
training pipeline that can at least help
to reduce the leakage things like
scrubbing pii limiting how much each
user
uh how much data from each user can be
contributed things like that
i'm just going to mention that there's
sort of a separate question uh
from all these which is uh what is
leaked during the training process and
that's also something that we're
interested in
and so we have sort of work streams on
federated learning and secure
computation
but i'm not going to talk about either
of those and right now in this today's
talk i'm going to focus only on this
problem of what a fully trained model
leaks about the training data
all right so i wanted to just give two
or three
um brief examples one in each of these
these categories to give sort of an idea
of what sorts of research i
we're considering in each of these areas
so the first is some work from some of
my colleagues at msr cambridge um
so this is looking at
uh again the problem of understanding so
looking at what models can leak
and in particular this is looking at the
setting where you have uh some say some
public model uh and then you
fine-tune it uh with private data and
release a private model and an attacker
you know naturally might have access to
the public model
and then also gets access to the to the
final um
fine-tuned model
and by access in this case i think i
mean
um
query access and and a little bit of the
the sort of confidence or probabilities
that come along with it
so the question is what can the attacker
learn about the sensitive data that was
used in in the the fine-tuning stage
uh i think a nice thing about this
attack is that it's taking into account
a very realistic part of the setting but
that's often sort of emitted in other
attack work
which is that you actually get access to
two models
so how does he i'm just going to give a
very high level idea of how the attack
works the basic idea is that you look at
at
the next word predictions made by the
model the public model and the private
model and you see how they change um so
if you have sort of an ordered
list of of the most likely next words uh
in this initial model so here in this
example it's our next meeting will be
the office and then you know tomorrow
the doc's home
and then after fine-tuning the the docs
has now moved up in probability so now
you can decide that most likely the docs
you know
our next meeting will be at the docs may
have been part of the training data
because the model has learned to pick
that up um
more strongly
um
so uh this
this work has shown that this kind of
attack actually does work and can
extract a lot of
uh sort of sensitive
uh data
and also that um
it also works you know not just in this
fine-tuning a public model but also
uh in the setting where you
continually update a model with with
some new data so say every month you
incorporate some new data and retrain
the model or
fine-tune the model
so it's fairly fairly broad
so the the next area that i wanted to
give an example of is this idea of
measuring leakage so here the goal is to
come up with some quantifiable metric
where we can say you know this is a
number that represents how leaky this
model is
um
so for this the example i wanted to talk
about is is in the text prediction
setting
so um
we have there are a number of products
that that will offer a text prediction
so you type the first half of the
sentence and it auto completes the rest
gives you a suggestion for how to finish
it
and
again the goal here is to be able to to
come up with some sort of numerical
value that that assesses the legal
content
and also to allow you to compare
different models trained on the same
training data
and see which is more private so this is
actually a very sort of simple metric so
the first thing you do is you look at
every data point in your training set
and so for example say one of the
sentences the training set is this is
the first step of our approach
so now you're going to type in each of
those words each of those prefixes so
first this you'll see what the language
model produces as a suggestion next it
says is
then you uh type in this is and it
produces an a and then you type in the
first three words which is in this case
this is the
and it gives you first and so on
and then we look at
then we look at for each of those
predictions which of them were correct
so is was correct uh for the next sort
of prefix it suggested
a the model suggested a the correct
answer was the so that's sort of wrong
then after that we got first step of all
correct in the row and then the
model suggested my method instead of our
approach so so the correct predictions
are is and first step of
and so we think of that as sort of the
private data that you can extract from
the model
and then to get a numerical value out of
this what we're going to do is we're
going to
look at the set of of correct
predictions that appears
in only one user's data so if it appears
in many different users data we don't
consider it private for this metric and
then we also want to rule out things
that maybe they appear in only a single
user's data but
they're really just natural speech there
it just happens that that you know
statistically this only occurred once
just by random chance
so the way we're going to do that this
is we're going to um
look at the perplexity according to a
public model that's trained on a
completely different data set
some public data set and look at
the ratio between that and the
perplexity
um
trained on this data set so it's sort of
getting a sense of how much more likely
is is this this sequence in our data
according to our model than in according
to the the public model so that allows
us to to rule out uh these sequences
that you know are decently likely
according to any model
it just so happens
so happens that they occur more often
here
and then we're going to look at the
maximum so we get a works case
result
and the idea here is that it measures
sort of how surprising you can say the
leakage of each unique sequence is with
respect to a public model
so as i said the other area that we've
been working on is looking at mitigation
so how can we reduce or prevent leakage
so the example i wanted to to talk about
here is some work from gopherdale and
other colleagues at msr redmond so here
the goal is um
we want to be able to find short email
responses
in some tests in in a office 365 that
we'll use for training ml models
uh so sort of that there are ad hoc
approaches one could use for this things
like key anonymity so dropping email
responses that don't appear too often um
and say filtering those with some kind
of human vetting process to make sure
that there's nothing that looks too
sensitive
um but that's not a great
uh approach
ideally because you can anonymity
we've it's been shown not to be rigorous
and and also just this human vetting
process doesn't scale to many languages
um
so uh the approach that we've taken is
is uh to use differential privacy so
that we'll uh collect a limited number
of responses from each user uh we use
those to compute a histogram so if the
the email responses are things like good
okay
no way i will we'll do yes no then we
can build this kind of histogram uh and
we'll add noise to every couch so that
we get differential privacy and return
only the responses that are above a
threshold
and you can prove that this satisfies
differential privacy so it guarantees
that it doesn't reveal any information
about an individual's data
and so this approach has been in
production in office 365 since fall 2019
and we actually now have more new more
powerful algorithms that just came out
of the research team that allow for
higher per user contributions to the to
the training data so as i said
originally we had to collect only a
limited number of responses and this
lets us um
use more of each user's data so throw
away less users data and still get the
same uh differential privacy guarantees
that we had
okay so the last thing that i that i
wanted to talk about that gives
hopefully sort of an overview of the
different kinds of research that we're
doing in this kind of this privacy in ml
space it spans the whole area from from
attacks to to defenses um and then i
wanted to talk to give a little bit more
detail on one topic and that that's the
project that i've been working on
um that looks it attacks on text-based
models
this again is in the category of just
understanding what models leak
so um
there are a lot of machine learning
models that are designed for for
language tests machine learning is very
very useful for this so the document
classification spam classification
sentiment analysis machine translation
smart composer smart reply all these
kinds of things
and again these these models are try
need to be trained on some kind of user
data
and
then there's a question of privacy and
the question worth looking at here in
particular is is it possible to tell if
a particular user's data was used in the
training process so so can a user
if they if they
choose try to find out if their data was
used to train the model
and in particular we're looking at uh
suppose supposing the user only has
access to the
to the only has query access to the
final model
so this captures gives us an idea of
sort of how much query access can reveal
about any particular user
so
membership inference attacks have been
actually studied uh for a while
um
and
the idea here is that an adversary tries
to determine whether a particular data
point has been used in the training set
of a machine learning model or not
so it's been used in different types of
models classification models generative
models and in this case we're going to
look at membership imprints
on
something called word embeddings which
i'll explain in a moment but it's an
underpinning of these text models
um and i guess two other things to point
out we're going to focus here on user
level
user level membership inference um
so meaning you know if we're training on
uh
say document collection zone by
different users or email data sets
produced by different users or chat data
sets or whatever it is
we're going to look at
the
whether that entire user's data was was
either you know included in the training
corpus or not
um
and this sort of more closely matches
intuitive privacy goals like other some
of these other models uh just consider
small sort of samples
um you know a couple words or a sentence
or something like that but a lot of
these training algorithms require at
least that an entire email be taken or
an entire document or something like
that a larger chunk uh so this lets us
uh sort of capture that attack more
accurately
um and i guess the other thing that i
think is interesting about our attack is
it's going to take advantage of a basic
feature of text models which is how
words are represented and the nice thing
about that is it means it can be
extendable to a number of different
settings a number of different different
text models
all right so um
to give a little more explanation of
about about this so
uh
a basic step before you can start
training any text based machine learning
model you have to have some way of
taking text and turning into a
mathematical object that you can feed
through your favorite neural network
so um the rough idea here uh is is which
is standard and in essentially all
models nowadays is we have some sort of
some space of of uh
words that you know some words are
semantically closer and we want to have
some way of of turning that into
a mathematical
vector essentially a vector of integers
um so you know once upon a time or
initially
approach would be like what's called a
bag of word models essentially there's a
vocabulary
and
say hello is the fourth word in the in
the vocabulary would be represented as a
vector with a one in that position and
zeros everywhere else so obviously this
isn't uh a great representation because
it's very long and so like these vectors
are huge and makes training very slow
your your networks are also very complex
and it also doesn't take into account
sort of semantic or contextual
information
so what most modern models use is
instead what's called a word embedding
and the idea here is that we're going to
map every word to a point in space
um
where it's essentially represented by a
vector of a fixed number of dimensions
and um
these are
built by you know it's the you train
them uh it's another essentially another
machine learning model trained by by
reading a huge corpus and the key part
is that it's trained to put words that
appear close together or that are
semantically similar
um
close together in the embedding space
so i'm going to
what we're going to look at is how to do
how we can apply our membership
inference attacks against these word
embeddings i'm going to talk first about
what would happen if we had direct
access to the word embedding and then
we'll see that that you don't actually
need access any that we can attack
models that are trained
um
on using a
a model that uses an embedding as a base
level but you know doesn't it directly
expose that embedding we can still
attack that kind of model
so just to give a brief idea of how our
experiments look we use the enron data
set which contains emails from different
users
a word embedding is trained on a subset
of half of the users and then a random
user is trying to find out if his data
is used in training or not
and our experiments measure sort of the
success probability of this of this
random user
so ideally a very secure uh our private
algorithm would not um
would uh this random user would only
have 50 50 chance of of guessing
correctly whether his data is included
or not
and our attacks will show that
at least standard word embeddings uh the
attacker can get much much better
success
so how is this how is this generally
done membership and prints attacks so as
i said this is an area that has been
studied and one way that it's uh people
often approach it is this idea of
looking at
the loss of an algorithm so learning
algorithms tend to sort of overfit a
little bit
and so the idea is that items in your
training data set you'll have less loss
than items that are that were not in the
trading data set so if you can get sort
of estimates about of this this loss
um
then uh you can estimate whether an item
was in the in or not in the data set
does this work for word embeddings not
directly um
it's not even clear what the loss
function is exactly
and uh
we need to figure out what the the right
sort of distinguishing function is
um
so we sort of use another uh
intuition which is based on on uh
looking at the the structure of these
embeddings looking at the goal of these
embeddings and again as i said these
modern embeddings the goal is to
put words that are semantically similar
or that appear
for words that are semantically similar
close to each other in the embedding
space and the way that it determines
generally whether words are semantically
similar is
it considers words that appear close to
each other in the text as
somehow semantically related
so
intuitively the
the ideas you know if i look at the
embedding space apple orange banana
those are all fruits they should be
close together if we've got you know
beverages are sort of mapped over here
transit left over here and then just you
can say
uh
in a
pre-2020 a
corpus maybe internship gets more up to
one
quadrant and remote gets mapped to a
very different quadrant these are slides
from one of my interns
um
and
but
if
and then that's because there's not you
know necessarily any any inherent
relationship between internship and
remote
but you know uh
in in the era of of covered in 2020 now
we've moved to remote internships and
now this phrase remote internship
becomes much more
common
uh so if we considered a corpus that
included emails sent in 2020 then a
remote internship would be mapped closer
together because those things appear
appear together
so the model would sort of learn to put
to put them close together in the
embedding space so the sort of rough
intuition of the attack is if we can see
these kinds of words that that are
distinguishing for our word pairs that
are distinguishing for the email corpus
that
that the user the for the user's data
set
um and and see whether those word pairs
are closer together or farther apart
then that helps us determine whether
this user's data was used or not used
so in this case we look at the word pair
remote internship and if those are
matched close together in the embedding
space we would say yes this
corpus of emails it has been used was
part of the training set and if they're
still far apart and then we would say no
it wasn't used
so the
the core of our attack is trying to find
these pairs of words and and define a a
distinguishing function based on the
distance between the words
and the nice thing is this is sort of
just a structural power uh property of
of embeddings
so um our basic attack basically say we
have uh
the the target data
which is a sequence of words so
um say w0 to ws
uh so think of that as the words in your
document your user's document or your
user's document collection or tenant's
document tenant's document collection
and then the address performs these
following steps so first
they sample a bunch of data sets that
all have either have the
um the sequence included or not included
so they just generate a bunch of random
data sets that are distributed
approximately like the real data
and then they train a bunch of what's
called in the literature shadow
embedding so these are just
taking each of these data sets uh and
and training and embedding
uh based on just that data set
and then it's going to query
each of these embeddings on all the
words in this data set
and compute the distances between the
embeddings of adjacent words so that
would be the distance between w0 and w1
between w1 and w2 and so on so that
gives you sort of a vector of
of distances for each
uh for each
pair of adjacent words and we'll put
them all those together and get one long
vector
and the sort of intuition is
that
these distances should be smaller
overall or at least for some pairs of
words if the target tenant data is used
then if they're not then if it's not
because again
if the target tenant is used and the
model has seen these words as being
close together so it in a sentence and
so it should map them close together in
the embedding space
and then finally we find a linear
function of these distances that lets us
uh
sort of separate these
shadow models that we trained using the
target data and the and the the shadow
models we trained without the target
data
and the nice thing about this is it's a
simple function so we actually don't
need to train too many models in in step
two often the expensive part of these
shadow model based attacks is is just
training these these shadow models so
the fact that we only need a simple
function means we don't have to train
too many and the attack can be fairly
efficient
so then finally having done that what
does the attacker do
so now they they if they have their
target set of words uh they again use
this um
process we said here to find this linear
function and actually we're going to
tweak the linear function a bit or
parameterize it uh to require that it it
uh only pick out a relatively small
number of words
um
or pairs of words
so that's going to give us a set of
important pairs of words and and this is
i think the
exact values for i think the enron some
subset of the the enron data set
um
and
uh
then the the attacker can determine
whether x is part of the data set by uh
just querying on these words and then
looking at the
computing the distances between the
resulting embeddings and looking at the
appropriate linear combination that that
it learned on the previous slide
uh so the actual attack part the rest of
it is all sort of pre-processing that
happens without even interacting with a
real trained model and the attack part
is just these two steps is really just
this step so querying the model on these
pairs of words in this case it would be
the list on the right and then
evaluating a linear function
saying yes if it's over the threshold
didn't know if it's below
ah so a couple other things we looked at
so one thing is is as i said you sort of
need to generate uh similar sets of
words so we actually did some
experiments where we
say the adversary uh has a different
distribution of email
data um
so we have a different email corpus uh
and uses those to generate shadow models
and
instead of the enron corpus
um
and
right
and the uh
the result was is that you can actually
still get fairly strong uh accuracy with
even with a slightly different data set
so we did experiments with against the
word
embedding and again this is the setting
where the embedding is is made public
um
the for the
uh
actual model and target data set so the
the we use the enron or subsets of the
enron data set
and then uh we trained our shadow models
either using other portions of the enron
data set or using a completely different
data set called avocado
but you can see that the membership uh
inference accuracy is actually pretty
good so we're getting you know in the
worst case uh
around uh
80 something percent accuracy and
getting up to high 90 accuracy so we can
actually do do fairly well
so that's all given access to the direct
access the embedding but realistically
an attacker is not going to have access
to the embedding in most cases what
they'll have access to is something
built with an embed the embedding is a
first layer so
we actually did look at this and we
looked at uh this is specifically a spam
classifier we think it should
carry it to other things
um
so they hear the idea is the attacker
only has access to
uh a classifier which will say whether
the the data
whether a particular email is spam or
not and look at whether they can use
that to tell
whether a particular
set of emails was was included in the
training set
and
the idea behind this attack is we'll
again run exactly the same attack as
above
to find the set of important words
because remember that doesn't require
access to the real model at all it's
it's all just models that the adversary
sort of trains in his head
and then uh
for each important word pair we query
the classifier on a bunch of emails
where
the emails are pairs of emails where the
pairs of emails are almost the same they
just replace
uh in this case w w prime
or swap w and w prime
and the intuition is that if w and w
prime are close in the embedding space
this should result in in similar
predictions
uh so this sort of gives us a way of
capturing the distance between the
embeddings just by looking at the the
predictions between these these sets of
documents
and
then we can use this again to train a
separator
um
using some shadow models and and
again
build a
a membership
um
so we ran experiments on this as well
and
we actually get recent attack accuracy
so um up to 98 in the case where the
attacker has access to the exact
distribution that the emails in the
target setter
are sampled from and and up to 86
percent when they're using this
alternate data set
so i'll just briefly mention we also
looked at a couple other things we
looked at what happens if only a subset
of users emails a user's emails are used
in the in the training set because a lot
of the time the first step in training
is just to sub-sample some a random
fraction of each user's emails
we also looked at
attacks on generative models in
particular lstm based models and we got
pretty good success there as well and
this also
attack also shows what happens if an
attacker uses a different embedding from
the target model so we used word to vect
for the shadow models in this attack but
then the target model that we're
attacking is an lstm based model
and the the nice interesting thing about
that is we can get much more lightweight
attacks because the shadow models we
need to train are mostly all using word
to vec
which is much much cheaper to train than
their lstm models
so just to sum up on on that topic uh we
looked at word embeddings and show that
they're definitely vulnerable to this
kind of membership inference attack user
level membership reference attack
this vulnerability exists even when the
embedding is not directly published or
provided as a service
just
it can potentially persist anywhere that
this embedding is used as the first
layer the first step in a text-based
model so that gives potential attacks on
a whole range of text-based models so
that we've only explored a few
experimentally
uh and the other interesting interesting
thing is the attack is efficient to
carry out so as i said it requires
relatively few shadow models and
those shuttle models can use a more
inexpensive embedding like board to bag
even if the final model actually has a
more sophisticated embedding
and i think interesting things about
this attack are first it's a user level
attack and we're taking advantage of
that um
by sort of picking out these word pairs
that are sort of what's special about
this user's data that would be a lot
harder to do if you only included say
one sentence of the user's data so here
we're using the fact that you use a
whole document or even a set of
documents
um that gives us more
potential to find these special word
pairs
and then there's some inherent
structures so adjacent words
are are assumed to have a
related meaning in any of these text
based contexts and we're taking
advantage of that
in our attack
so that's all i'm going to say about our
attack just to sort of wrap up i think
this area of privacy and ml it's very
important it has lots of really
interesting problems and a lot of open
problems so i think it's hopefully
something that a lot more people will
get involved in
um
from our point of view i guess some of
the interesting questions on the
understanding side for example
are
can we better take advantage of of of
the problem settings or inherent
structures as we did in this embedding
attack or or as the snapshot attack did
that i mentioned earlier
um
there's also other you know interesting
questions on what about attacking not
individuals but larger subgroups uh
organizational leakage that kind of
thing
and maybe are there other attacker goals
that would be interesting to look at
besides membership inference and and
training data extraction so people have
looked at
uh property inference a little bit um
but i think there's probably a wide span
of things that you can look at in terms
of what leaks about the training data
on the measuring side again we need to
look at how to turn these attacks into
efficiently compare computable metrics
so that we can evaluate our our
mitigations and on the mitigation side
of course
improving dp and bringing it
closer to practice and into use and
practice whenever possible and then
designing and analyzing heuristic
mitigations for the places where dp is
not applicable or
um can't yet be used
so uh
i'll stop there and and just say i hope
you found something interesting in there
and and potentially that you'll you'll
join us in this effort
in this research space thanks